everyone welcome back and let's write
some more neat code today so today let's
solve the problem k the largest element
in a stream and it's marked as an easy
question but i definitely feel that it's
more of a medium and maybe that's why
many people disliked it but we are told
to design a class to find the kth
largest element in a stream of numbers
so stream basically means that we could
continue to add numbers to the list of
numbers after we do that we still have
to find the kth largest element now that
we've added more numbers to it and they
say that the kth largest element is the
case largest in the sorted order not
distinct and what they mean by that is
basically that if we had you know this
uh list of numbers and k equals three
meaning we want the third largest number
if we look at the distinct values we'd
say okay three is the largest two is the
second largest and one is the third
largest but they say we want to return
the case largest in sorted order meaning
this is the first largest this is the
second largest and this is the third
largest so we return two we're not just
looking at distinct elements if we have
multiple copies we include those as well
the good thing is we only need to
implement two functions one is the
constructor where we'll be given the
parameter k that we can store and an
initial list of numbers and this list of
numbers it could be at least k elements
or it could be less than k elements or
it could be more than k elements so
that's something we're gonna have to
take care of when we do write out the
code uh but the second function is the
add function where we can actually add a
number to the stream of data and this
function is also going to return the new
kth largest element every time we call
it so
they do tell us that whenever we call
this function we are guaranteed to have
at least k elements in the stream of
data so that's good even though we might
not have k elements when we initialize
it we will have k elements when we call
the add function so now the question is
how can we efficiently solve this
problem well suppose we were given this
input right in our constructor this
array and k equals three of course the
intuitive approach is to sort the input
so that we can uh you know look through
and find the kth largest element a
little bit faster right in the original
array we could just scan through the
entire input and that'd be o of n to
find the kth largest but when the array
is sorted though we can of course use
binary search which will run in log n
time but the problem is if we want to
insert a new value for example we want
to run add on the value three well yeah
we can run binary search to add the
number as well we can find where to
insert it but when you insert in the
middle of an array it's a linear time
operation big o of n so the question is
is there a better approach is there a
different data structure we can use and
yes there actually is and the data
structure that's going to help us the
most in this case is a min heap and we
are going to require it to be of size k
and let me tell you why well first of
all a heap is a data structure if you
haven't heard of it that has a somewhat
sorted property we can add and pop
elements from the min heap in log n time
we can also get the minimum value of the
min heap in big o of one time obviously
this is a little bit better than an
array especially an unsorted array like
we are given in the input but the
question is why are we going to require
it to be of size k and why are we using
a min heap rather than a max heap well
one thing we are going to use to our
advantage is that we're only going to be
adding elements to our stream of data
we're never really going to be removing
anything so in this example we're given
four numbers but we only need a min heap
of size k because we only need the k
largest values from the array in this
case it's four five and three why is
that why do we never need the two
because we want the third largest value
this is the largest this is the second
largest this is the third largest so we
have three numbers that are bigger than
two is two ever going to be the third
largest value in our stream of data it's
never going to be because we're never
going to remove any of these elements
right we might add elements we might add
a value like six if we add this six
value then we don't want to include this
f this four anymore then we only want to
keep track of these three numbers six
five and eight and now this is going to
be the third largest number five is
going to be the third largest number two
is never going to be included in this
group two is never going to be in our
min heap of size k if we added a small
element to our stream like a 1 well we
don't care about a 1. now in terms of
the code and how we're going to
implement this we're going to have a min
heap of size k first of all what we're
going to do to get this heap is we're
going to take this entire input and add
it to the min heap right so suppose we
have four five and eight in our min heap
now we're going to do a while loop while
the size of the heap is greater than k
we're gonna pop the minimum
value in this case the minimum is 2
we're going to pop it thankfully now our
heap is size k exactly so we don't need
to continue to pop elements and remember
our min heap we can get the minimum
value and since we have these are the
three largest values we want the third
largest which is going to be the minimum
among all of these i hope now you can
see why we're using a min heap because
we can get the minimum in o of one time
but the add function over here requires
us to add a value to our stream of data
so for example suppose we want to run
add 3
well how do we know if 3 is included
among our k largest values well the
easiest way to do it there's multiple
ways but the easiest is just to take
that 3 and add it to our min heap so now
we have 4 values in our min heap and we
we added it in log n time now we want to
pop the minimum value from this min heat
because we want the third largest value
we have four values in the heap let's
pop the smallest one which is three we
can do that again in login time and now
we want to know okay among the remaining
what's the smallest value again it's
four so as you can see we can do the add
function in log n time how many times
are we going to run the law in the add
function who knows let's call it m and
then this is going to be the overall
time complexity of add if we count all
the function calls that are made to it
now in terms of our
constructor function actually generating
this entire heap it's potentially going
to be n log n in the worst case reason
being is we can actually initialize the
heap like this is our input data we can
turn it into a heap in o of n time
that's not too bad but then remember
when we started with the array we had
this two right we have to keep popping
elements until we only have k elements
remaining so
a pop function is gonna be log n time
how many times are we gonna have to pop
potentially n minus k times so this is
the overall time complexity k could be
really small it could be one so you know
worst case we could have n log n for our
constructor but the add function is just
going to be log n that's a big
improvement over the first solution we
came up with which was uh end time when
we were just using a array structure so
heaps definitely help us out a lot now
we can go ahead and code this up now
let's code it up first thing we're going
to do is the constructor you can see i
have one comment that hopefully will
help guide us
in the code so we can create a member
variable with the self keyword in python
so first we want to create our min heap
and we also want to have another member
variable for k which is you know going
to be the size of that heap or at least
the desired size of it so min heap
initially can just be assigned to nums
and our k is just going to be assigned
to the input parameter k we want to turn
this into a heap right now it's just a
array we can turn it into a heap in
python like this heap q dot heapify
keepifying this array into a min heap
that will create the sorted property it
will run in big o of n time but it could
be that it has more than k element so
while the length of self.min he is
greater than k we can go ahead and pop
from the min heap we can do that with
heap q dot heap pop
on the min heap data structure and don't
forget the keyword self since it's a
member variable so the constructor isn't
too bad now let's do our add function
there's multiple ways you could write it
but the easiest way is just to go ahead
and add this value to our min heap
regardless of what it is if it's too big
or if it's too small who cares we can go
ahead and say heap q dot
this value
and then we're gonna pop the smallest
value which might end up being this
value or it might end up being a
different value who knows let's go ahead
and just pop it and our heap data
structure will actually take care of
that for us anyway
but there's actually just one edge case
that you might miss remember our heap
might be initialized with less than k
elements this loop will execute if it
has more than k elements which is good
but what if it has less than k elements
then if we add a value to the heap we
don't want to pop from the heap if it
has less than k elements or even equal
to k elements we only want to pop if the
length of the min heap is greater than k
elements so if it's greater than k
that's when we want to pop from the min
heap but once we've done that we make
sure our heap is valid it does have k
elements we're guaranteed that when the
add function runs so now we just want to
return the minimum from our min heap and
the way heaps are implemented the
minimum value will always be stored in
the zeroth index so we can just go ahead
and return
this
and don't be dumb like me we forgot to
when we're referencing min heap and the
k value we want to make sure we
reference it as a member variable so
let's use the keyword self
self.min heap okay it looks good to me
let's run it to make sure that it works
and as you can see on the left yes it
does work and it's about as efficient as
we can get so i really hope that this
was helpful if it was please like and
subscribe it really supports the channel
a lot consider checking out my patreon
where you can further support the
channel and hopefully i'll see you
pretty soon thanks for watching